on as far as i know can you hear me now
okay
um great so
um welcome to the last event of the day
for today except for dinner we have a
discussion panel um i'll briefly
introduce the panelists because if i
introduce them fully that'll take up
half the panel i'll just tell you their
names judging fan from princeton been
you from berkeley peter bowman from eth
peter beckham
i don't need to introduce him john
mcculloch who is at volley on and uc
berkeley and taoshi from citadel
so uh what we're going to do is um
i will start with asking
a few starter questions um but i um
don't want to be asking all the
questions um so then
it'll go over to the audience
and um i hope you will all
um have things to ask
so um
what i what i'd like to start with is
um which is of course one of the reasons
we're here is celebrating peter's long
career um
statistics has grown enormously over the
time that he has been active there are
many more topics and people and journals
and papers
um and what i'd like to ask is what do
you think has been has stood the test of
time over these years what are the
themes that occurred
all your careers that are still relevant
that were the most important that didn't
fade into the past and and i'd like to
start with peter
thank you
is this audible
you hear me
all right this is good you could put
this down peter i can put it
[Laughter]
forgive me for for my
technological uh incompetence uh
and also forgive me because i'm going to
read just to make sure that i
uh
don't
freeze up uh so first of all of course
these are my opinions and they're only
largely relevant to theory because
despite
some indications of my interest in
applications
that's still what i've basically spent
my life on so
fundamental changes have occurred in all
aspects of society because of the
development of technology so
particularly the computer
but also miniaturization and new ways of
measuring
and the implications for statistics have
been in the amount of data the types of
data and the feasibility of analyses of
the data
the union with machine learning and ai
as part of the newly defined field of
data science has also come out of that
and this is the is the uh i think the
reason that we have had this increase in
people journals conferences
and this particular conference being
held under the auspices of the simons
institute and cdss
okay so now the the question about
themes so
themes appear disappear and reappear
during this period
under various names and with very
different emphases
stochastic approximation applied to
regression has become stochastic
gradient descent applied to everything
[Applause]
sequential analysis is always there but
has a big new center of importance as
online analysis of data
uh
there's some larger examples multiple
comparisons
testing was
has always again been with us but has
been brought forward to the fore by the
need to make many simultaneous judgments
in biology and other fields
post-selection inferences again always
been a concern go back to the chauffeur
intervals but there's been an explosion
of new work
there have been big thematic changes as
far as i can think computational
performance has to be combined
with inferential performance so general
mathematical descriptions which are okay
in the papers that i originally wrote
in terms of optimization are not enough
algorithms need to be at least
written
if not necessarily feasible
[Laughter]
randomness has become an essential tool
again it's always been present
experimental design randomization tests
but now i think it's become essential
monte carlo cross validation the gibbs
sampler the bootstrap and many others
there are what i view at least as
unchanged features at least in my view
of statistics
is the probabilistic models
abstraction and representations are
still at the base of statistics
to say anything
i think we always have at some level to
think of the data as approximately
independent approximately identically
distributed structures possibly
conditional and other parts of data or
unobserved latent variables
we have non-parametric models have
become uh
paramount but in fact semi-parametric
models are of course with us still and
then there's the other axes of bayes
empirical bays
uh latent variables and so on
analysis has
remained i think really largely the same
by approximation
and by simulation
approximation
view all asymptotic theory including
non-asymptotic bounds
as approximations
[Music]
there are some new features though of
course again there's been an emphasis on
high dimension
on sparsity complexities parameters as
important as sample size
and the north non-asymptotic bounds
which i've
always complained about because they're
really asymptotic theory without the
specification of unknown constants
do give qualitative information
however the basic questions remain and i
think
some of these were alluded to in various
talks but in particular events uh also
talk
which factors covariance
matter
another way which ones are are causal
how far can we extrapolate
in conflict and causal inference and in
prediction
right the population can change
uh and
prediction is no longer valid
uh
and of course uh
and uh
in causal inference confounding factors
or factors which you don't know about at
all
and then finally the third point which i
think is
really fits with what ben said
particularly is that we need can we
explain
can we predict in terms of things we
understand
that's
that's
remains open while entirely verbal but
forever
because of course what we understand
changes as time goes on
uh there are themes which at least are
left less interest to me
uh the bayesian versus frequentest
definition
uh bayesians who are bayesians these
days all who use bayes rule
or all who use models whose analysis
requires gibb samplers
i'm not sure
second i this is
this is anathema i think the asa
the correct use of p-values and bayes
factors
as opposed to
not given not to my colleague then good
scientific practice
which i think is is what matters really
i even found a theme which is dead
statistical tables
now what what directions of importance
are
because i see them
fostering interdisciplinary interaction
we have to remember that we can play in
everybody's backyard and we should
continue to do so
creating data science is a unified
discipline
with exploration prediction in tandem
with computation
and
i believe confirmation
which is discipline specific
for example i believe for example the
whole controversy on p p values and
replicability
are tied to weak signals
much less of an issue let's say in
physics or many other views
and that's the end of my pontificate
ask questions
[Laughter]
no it's like everyone can contribute
well okay let me ask the next question
then um
i think in this in this
big data um
era
we have all got very good at explaining
that statistics is part of data science
to our colleagues and deans and to
everybody
there are a lot of people in other
fields who do some of the same things
that we do um
what i'd like to ask is
what are the unique contributions of
statistics to data science what do we do
that nobody else does and that they
can't do without
what do we bring to the table
in your view
i guess i was asked to start on this
so
it's very interesting because uh
percussive for the last eight years
have
really
made the case that we're part of data
science so we succeeded moving into the
division of
computing data science and society
actually exactly in the face to explain
to the dean how we're different
so i think we need to play both and both
are true so things the question is about
how
we're different
and i want to follow up on what peter
said
that
peter says that he does theory actually
i think peter actually does at least
when you talk to him he does relevant
theory
and
he might not agree to me but that's how
i see him
and that's where i think
the statistics people can play a huge
show
is providing the relevant theory very
coupled with intelligent research
like i think jeff's talkies was also
examples that really get into the
science and bench talk today it's really
tried to do the integration and i think
i like to kind of amend what tukey said
statistician played in everybody's
backyard i think we should play in
aberdeen's front yard
because we actually have the tradition
of getting into science
and also we have the technical and
computing we're really the glue i think
when i first met um ben through um peter
i think i used to call him uh in front
of me and behind him called him the
super glue
radical he made many connections among
different people and
i think that's the role i think
statistician can play is really care
about science equally with the
methodology
and also the algorithms and in a way
like freedom will call shoe leather work
so all of that i think is actually our
unique strengths right that's why i
talked to jennifer chase that's actually
the argument i've been putting forward
we are have some unique
um history
and also strengths at the same time i
think we need to embed our skill sets
and our critical rigor
into
the context of modern problems
and we need to really do much better as
jessica was advocating and i agree very
much we have to communicate
very well and bring with our expertise
to the people of
like our customers instead of waiting
for them
to come to us it's just not happening
and the software
extremely important embed our
algorithm into software and write blogs
which i
twitter i don't do twitter but that's
what people
um was surprised this morning a
collaborator in neuroscience say well
you don't get your sign from twitter
and i said well i still read papers
but things like that i think it's what
we need to move but i think our
traditions here our carefulness is here
and when we really engage in problems i
think we are really necessary
and i think the whole ai and data
science are really proper because we're
there but we do have to change our work
and the culture to engage
[Laughter]
perfect statement nothing to add
yeah well everybody's giving such
perfect answers
um why don't i ask um
one of you to say what you know from
your position in industry when you when
you look at the decisions what do you
think when you hire a statistics phd why
is that
uh
yeah i think um
there are real architect types in our
field in statistics and
you know you spend a lot of time
in graduate school and then in your
career working and seeing these things
and maybe don't have
a kind of service level awareness that
many people who are doing
applied science and data science and
thinking about
computation and algorithms they have
they aren't aware of these archetypes
okay and so we have
we have a way of thinking about
uncertainty
that really is sort of
differentiate differentiates us and so
when i
you know for example talk to people who
i'm considering as future colleagues or
when i
work with our phd students in our
consulting course
i think that you know i make i make a
real
attempt to
capture that attitude of knowing
archetypes of uncertainty and
recognizing categories of of inference
problems and you know being able to take
somebody's
messy and and maybe not completely
unambiguous scientific question and
uh find a way to
[Music]
move it around
just enough to fit it into something
that is familiar where we know what good
practical answers are and we know what
the assumptions are behind those answers
and we can check them and do the right
kind of exploratory data analysis we
encourage everyone to look at the data
first but there's an unbounded number of
ways to look at the data you want to
look at the data in a way that's
guided towards an eventual attempt to
solve the problem at hand um
and i would emphasize that that is
really special to statistics and to us
that even even if you branch out a
little bit into machine learning and and
kind of related fields there's much less
of a qualitative feel for managing and
reasoning about uncertainty
and that's that's something that we can
really positively contribute to
thanks john um
thanks very much for actually inviting
me to be on this panel i'm really
honored so
um
well i think there is a reason the
question is about our contribution to
the so-called data science you know
field there is a reason why i look back
actually most of the statistics
department is in the college of art and
science
or a few of you cannot think much
actually in the college of engineering
so
everyone has mentioned actually we are
working on cleaning everyone's backyard
try trying to help them to use data to
answer their scientific questions
scientific somehow stands out very
significantly to me to think about
actually when we think about the data
science do we really cover engineer
maybe maybe not but if i think about
twitter think about facebook what are
they doing they're basically using data
to make money
and make people maybe make people happy
right but but they are really really
using data to do something but not
necessarily doing some science
but do we really cover them do we really
want to play in their backyard i i don't
know
are we good at it i don't know
so in some sense uh for example citadel
which is a supposed trading trading
company but what it really does is
analyzing data and based on data to
actually putting decision on trading
that's it right so
not much anything else it's really
manipulate data data learning from data
and make decisions
so do we really cover this type of
science as well so called data science
is definitely not science
so
so to me i think this data science is
much broader than only doing science we
are actually helping
if we are doing this right we should be
able to help everyone who use data to
make decisions to do things better i
think that's probably one place we can
go better but how to do better i think
it depends on all the
everyone in the community to really to
push out our students and also
make our students our faculty to be able
to do slightly broader things other than
only science
so to um to follow up on the data
science theme um
all of those
of us who are in academia have seen how
excited the students are
and there's a lot of new interests um
[Music]
undergrads want to do data science they
don't necessarily know what it is
they're not necessarily prepared to do
it the way we want them to but there's a
lot of excitement
so how do we capitalize on that new
level of interest how do we take
advantage of that to broaden the pool of
students we work with and and maybe turn
some of them into statisticians but
still keep it statistics
as as we just described it can you start
teaching
stay at the corners
[Laughter]
now i can see you
well uh so first of all thank you for
invitation and great to be here happy
birthday peter got much to talk to you
it's very busy days uh yeah so uh well
this is really a great question right so
i have been a solo in the department for
so long and
our department operation research and
financial engineering have traditionally
has lots of undergraduate students
and i believe the first phase when we
have this department people are
attracted by financial engineering and
after
uh financial crisis
our i mean everybody becomes like a more
data science so the first thing
is like how do we and our departments
continue to be popular because of data
science and then the first thing is i
mean for me at least there are two
opportunities that i could communicate
well with students the first one is
through
teaching the first class of
undergraduate studies the class so many
of us indeed for me until 2016 and to
1991 when i started teaching is really
the same same material right so after
2016 i really add a lot of examples
applied to different disciplinaries
more computational based
and i insist that my class should not be
stopped at two-sample t-test because
then student cannot get a chance to see
what is my normal life because they were
thinking my moral life is to sample t
tests or analysis of contingency tables
so i insist that they should have at
least multiple regression they got a
chance of
learning testing
those kind of concepts even
cross-validation
even model selection where you do
polynomial regression or spline
these are very easy to introduce and i
was a little bit more ambitious
unfortunate principle have only 12 weeks
i insist giving one week on introduction
to i mean data science or machine
learning whatever you want to call
unfortunately i have to
to abandon it because there are only two
12 weeks so much for me to teach so i
think it's very important for
when you are student what is your future
perspective they always say i want to do
data science i want to do ai very few
people say i want to do statistics right
so then
the next sentence i say well so if you
have to learn something
undergraduate or even back one more step
in high school so where you should
emphasis
so they would say oh well math right i
say okay well this in the right
direction right so if you want to do ai
data science math so when you do
undergrad
undergraduate students right so in
addition to math now you should realize
that the data science is not just
programming language there's a lot of
ai it's not just programming language
i'm able to write programs but you
should be able to do like a statistical
reasoning so i try to say to them that
statistics uh is really part of
foundational data science where you want
to see data science not in abstract but
in something but more real uh then will
see that and of course through the
teaching we have to give them i mean a
lot of
examples now the second
case that i have
that
deeply interact with students is our
senior thesis so through senior thesis i
always say that now you all holding data
science skills right so let's find some
problem to work on and through that work
they realize more and more the
usefulness of statistical uh i mean
modeling and uncertainty quantifications
and so on so
i think undergraduate education
convinced them that student is
the first step to data science i think
it's very very important and i'm pretty
sure there are so many other people here
who have way more to say than what i
want to say here but
let me just quit
did you here to ask yeah i think deaf
nolan is supposed to be on the panel
since dev's not here i tried to
impersonate that yeah
because uh i think
that el nino john dinero be better to
speak about the data science program
even i was engaged with one particular
course
so
since 2014
so there have been this attempt to
really modernize statistics and
computing the same time this influential
thinking and computing thinking meet in
data science courses so data eight was
designed with joint faculty from both cs
and stat department anin jandira with
the poster masters of teaching and dev
and joe
gonzalez um really
i was on the team to do data 100. so
these are huge classes with 1000
of our students and one phenomenon
is really that they also
nurturing a whole generation of
undergraduate
research like
gsi's in berkeley college um
ugsi i think that's how they're called
so they really like each team can have
50 students and
they
become a community of people and really
become high teachers
and do tutoring so they have different
steps so that really changed the whole
landscape of undergraduate teaching we
never use in statistics as many we never
use many at all undergraduate students
and many of them go on to graduate
schools i think because they actually
connect with graduate students much
better
but of course it's pretty heavy teaching
as my two cheers can sandra and haiyang
will tell you
uh it needs to be really
a balance but in terms of from student
point you actually am a parent of two
students who come through this it's a
huge uh success from the student point
of view and um and now there's also one
two i think um
fernando perez and mike jordan and mike
jordan from the press have been
spearheading and many people thought i
haven't really studied that so it's
another class so there has been the
foundation actually the new division i
don't think without the courses the um
berkeley division would have as much
argument to the administration
and another
signature of data eight is being copied
by many universities i think yale
actually used the same curriculum and
many other places
yeah and michigan
and has really created both i think a
teaching culture revolution also
curriculum is like your program while
you do statistics and there are
connected classes for data eight
that you can get to modern mathematical
data derivations you have a connection
in statistics and kind of a connecting
neuroscience you can have a connector in
chemical engineering i don't know that
has happened so that also connects
respect to how the unique
contribution the tradition of fisher and
box and people like that is really
through these connectors i think data
100 will be great to have also such
connector classes but i think it's a
human resource problem and to follow out
what jen ching was saying that we also
have machine learning classes that both
cs and stats and cs have announced two
versions i think
and what i thought that the machine
learning
it's also the same i try to bring the
research
to the undergraduate level instead of a
t-test and actually i do the machine
learning way and go to inference later
you do prediction first because they see
what they can do and then you go to the
more refined and introduce very very
carefully
a random
variable
and i think that's what i hope by
impressing that okay um
to follow up on students um so once they
do go on to graduate school um
and
assuming at that point we have convinced
them that they're doing statistics and
we teach them a lot of things some of
which you know they use later on and
some of which they don't
um looking back at the
many years you've been doing this what
do you think are the most important
things for phd students to learn in
graduate school
what really stays
so this is my turn now
maybe i should also add um
of course the undergraduate education is
very different in europe and that also
makes the programs quite different but
on the graduate level we're probably
more similar also that
what happens here
um so the skill sets a bit my personal
opinion i'm not a big fan of kind of
telling my students that they should
learn a particular skill set because i
think this is really an education also
graduate school it's a basis for the
next 20 30 or 40 or 50 years and that
maybe the landscape will change quite a
bit so but i do what i do encourage them
very much is point number one in
graduate school
on the thesis work
that they really should try to shape
their own research agenda very early on
of course i helped them i think it's
important to introduce them but i really
would like to see my students developing
very quickly somehow their own direction
i think this is tremendously important
for
further academic
career
but also in industry it's important that
you you take the lead you have your own
vision your own ideas so this is in a
way my number one
my number two is
in terms of scope of course students are
totally different and that's good it's
great but i tell them they should go
deep in two subfields so they have uh
maybe they start with one but i strongly
encourage them that they go a bit deeper
or deep in another one i mean it could
be say mathematical theoretical and also
a very applied project and so on and so
forth i think this is uh important it's
good and i think it's also part
of maybe the statistical culture that
it's it's broad right and um
so i i i think this is a very important
uh second point going deep in at least
two areas
uh the third thing which i think is
is kind of a skill set is communication
i think this becomes extremely important
communication in written and oral form
so this is something a scale maybe which
needs to be trained and learned
and uh so i think this is super
important and the fourth it has been
mentioned already a bit it's kind of um
team spirit i think more and more
in statistics and in many many areas in
science it will be done in teams also
certainly in industry i guess i have
never worked in industry but
so
team spirit at least so of course if a
student doesn't want a real do team work
at least the student should develop team
spirit and uh even more so if they do
teamwork that is something i would also
strongly encourage
people would you like to
yeah
[Laughter]
you did a great job
everything i would have said you already
said but maybe i'll pick one thing which
is
writing
i think
essentially nobody writes well when they
get to graduate school i
definitely count myself in that category
and so one thing that i really encourage
the students i've worked with to focus
on is
to spend the time to produce a document
that you think you're going to be proud
of in 10 years
because
you know the research you're doing is
interesting and there's a chance that
people will be reading it 10 years from
now
and
you know i've had the experience of
reading something i wrote 10 years ago
and cringing right so and you need to
how do you get good at writing you read
a lot and you write a lot you know
there's you need to look at you as a as
an as an advisor you can show your
students really well written papers
really badly written papers there's no
shortage of both
and and ask them to explain what the
difference is and and it's easy when you
look at good papers they're obviously
good
and you know the same often goes for bad
papers so
just i encourage everybody think of it
as a skill that is absolutely as
important and on par with verbal
communication with you know re getting
getting research done etc
thanks john so um i think if like most
of our students go to academic of
graduation then i would just shut up
i will try to
provide a slightly different perspective
from like if i'm in industry i'm trying
to hire some students or looking for
some stat phd graduates if i want to
hear them what the property or maybe
help them to get uh working well in like
a
and this industry i'm working right now
so now what i did i actually went back
to do some some sampling i did a
snowball sampling of whatever
certifications are working on my floor i
asked them this question about like what
do you think is the you know students of
the statistical training you have
you have you have get and also what do
you think which might be a little bit
better if you want you hope it's a
little bit better so
the strength i got back is i have a note
here actually so the main is a data
skill there are two level of data skills
one is like i guess in sample data skill
really when you deal with data like how
to clean clean data how to you know
manage data how to manipulate data those
are example data skills and then there
is the auto sample data skill which
means you have to think beyond data
think about like confounders and you
know things which you haven't you see
the data but that's those factors will
determine how you get the data and maybe
what will lead your conclusion to be
biased away from just your data so like
this inside out of example both data
skills are very important for answering
questions
at the same time what they said they
said they hope they can actually learn
more or learn better is some kind of
computational skill
so in some sense i don't mean you run uh
our package just you know throw your
data into our package run lm then you
get the coefficient that p-value
altogether but uh what they think they
want to know more or what will help them
more is actually to knowing how the
package handles the data if you want to
attribute some better lm how do you do
it and if your data size is so huge then
how do you actually write your code and
send your data to parallel computing and
run your lm efficiently so those are the
computation skills i think we teach in
some in some degree but uh it probably
will take a little bit more for the uh
for the faculty and also maybe maybe
encourage them to go out of our
department go to computer science go to
more like a more hardcore computing
class to to learn they think that will
be very beneficial for them
yeah i think that for graduate education
probably that's what i learned from my
cluster sampling again that's very
biased from
from what i know there's lots of other
people who don't need it but at least
for the things i see that's one of the
things important
so i'll ask my last question and then
i'll um turn it over to the audience and
this is perhaps the most important one
um
traditionally we focus on our methods
and our theory and our applications
maybe
data science but we all know that big
data has affected humans has affected
society
in very real ways and many of his ways
are good many of these ways are bad and
we often
don't think about it perhaps as much as
we should
so how do you see the role of
statisticians in
mitigating the bad
increasing the good
um
in terms of the impact on actual human
life
i'm supposed to start
on this one i mean
you know to the extent that
i talk about practicing what i preach i
think
some of the new problems are just the
old problems at larger scale like
helping people in one way or another be
critical consumers
of the stuff they read in the news the
the you know understanding
the kind of what at berkeley we would
call the stat two
nuts and bolts of what what's what's a
sensible analysis and what's a
nonsensical
analysis um
we are always going to have a role to
play in that i think
you know
i i don't know a field that has as much
corporate understanding of causal
inference and the difficulties of causal
inferences as statisticians and and
maybe biostatisticians
so we're always going to have to take
the lead on that um and
you know certainly berkeley statistics
and and peter and colleagues from
of many decades have
a very long-standing tradition of being
deeply involved in those kinds of public
policy discussions and and in a way that
kind of really moved the needle
um i'm personally not sort of that's not
the thing i do but it's it's a big part
of the berkeley statistics tradition
um
i guess there are
some also issues that are just brand new
and those have to do with things like
um privacy and the way that uh
you know large companies that are
acquiring
voluminous data sets about
the entire population of of the us or
the or the world uh what actions they
take and how they behave and
um i guess i haven't reasoned much about
exactly what the special role is that
statisticians should play as as opposed
to others but i'd be curious
if anyone else on the panel has or what
what other thoughts are but uh
you know
we as the
enforcers of of sound scientific method
and
and reasonable causal inferences we're
always going to have kind of that that
position to take i think
maybe i'll uh
at one point um this is
maybe just a very small part of
statistics so i just mentioned a name
and then you can connect probably quite
quickly so what the david spiegelhalter
does the communication
of numbers of risk i think certainly
during covet this had a huge impact but
also
before i mean he had
a big impact on the
medical health system in the uk
it's just it's really only explaining to
the public to the decision makers um
it's it's a small
area i think in our field
but
some people
have engaged very much and with much
success and i think that's great and
it's very important and
this is something which i definitely see
as a
a task where
statistics had an impact
on society
just to add to what has been said i
think it's very interesting i was on the
causality program at simon's here
and they actually invited a lawyer
who studied fairness because a lot of
the fairness question had been framed
through the counterfactuals and they
actually invited lawyer to be part of
the program so there's a lot of
interactions between social scientists
who somebody who know the legal um rules
and with the culture influence people i
thought that was very fruitful
discussion i get to talk to her and
many others so they also in terms of
what john was talking about written
communication they also had like science
writer in residence
continuously and they have theoretical
speaking
series which is broader so i think those
are the things we can really learn from
the computer science community this is
mostly and
if you look at the 10th anniversary
celebration
last week
and this really this is
called
institute of australian computing right
theory is actually in there
but the breadth of talks they have i
think they take a very expensive view of
strategic computer science and i think
that's something we could also do that
take a very expensive view of
statistical even mathematical statistics
i think eventually it's i'll call it
globalization right fields not countries
and it's healthy
and
in terms of the
graduate students
i think
would be nice if we have
asa or have a camp a talk to speak order
right have him to really train the next
generation of people how to communicate
and i think those all the things
young people can ask ims to do i think
that i'm as president here
[Laughter]
and
oh you're the past but they can pass to
the next president
so i think
it's communication and engagement
we closer to problems i think will
really benefit the whole field and to
show well basically you have to prove we
are
useful
yeah
let me add something to topic number
four on graduate education just slightly
change your gear right so we
yeah i'm always telling student a very
simple sentence which is not really
quite true i say learn how to learn i
learn from peter i think what i'm doing
now is very different you know when i
was a student here so i mean learn how
to learn is important but for my own
collaboration
with uh let's say economist in
particular the area right so nowadays
data is everywhere so in the education
part we probably didn't emphasize as
much
to collect it ourselves so there's a lot
of database i mean uk biobank
i mean all those newswire data it's all
there so it and
we didn't really teach students as much
i encourage them to find uh different
data so my own experience is like we
were trying to use
my life data to predict housing
activeness in purdue
and after we're working very hard out of
sample our square still pretty low so we
realized that i mean the
uh i mean the bright area could be
airport could be uh other right so this
would be very useful to look for let's
say land planning data give you an idea
to further decompose
these kind of confounding factors so
when i'm working with economists they
are very easily when something doesn't
work they're looking for new data
we will educate when something doesn't
work working very hard on a different
learning methods and that i do need to
be changed somehow so just i just want
to add a little bit to that
yeah i just want to amplify this learn
how to learn i think that's what we try
to do i know so in terms of interim
research berkeley has a tradition of
215a
many many generations and i have the
fortune to have been teaching the recent
time and i know lisa brought it to
michigan
so i think
yeah
but i think this is something it's a
more scalable way than just one-on-one
coaching
so thank you all very much um so great
to um listen to all the answers um i'd
like to turn it over to the audience now
um
um just raise your hand and i'll i'll
pass the mic over
thanks lisa and thank you all for a
wonderful panel um
really enjoyed all the comments and i
just wanted to follow up about two of
them so one of them is the bin's
point about the central role that
education has played in building this
new division of data science so there's
an upcoming workshop
um on special workshop on data science
education it's at the end of the month
june 27th to 30th it's hybrid so
basically diving deeper into all the
courses
that ben um has described and then the
second point about john that john made
about the importance of writing
um even if that was here she probably
wouldn't have said it but that wrote a
book
about writing
and it's on david aldous's list of
highly recommended books so
you know you might want to take a look
at that so just advertising for good for
good product placement
so i just wanted to expand a little bit
on something that peter mentioned in his
opening comments but the importance of
facilitating interdisciplinary
interaction um and i know ben mentioned
like writing blogs being on twitter um
and the the importance both of
statistical knowledge diffusing in other
disciplines but also knowledge from
other disciplines diffusing into our own
in order to know that you're doing
relevant theory you need to have some
notion of like what theory might be
relevant
and as as someone who came to statistics
from outside it can be a very
intimidating temple to approach
and so i'm curious if you can comment
you know there's there's ways to do very
very focal interaction right that i
think we do well and maybe we can do
more of where you can really influence
science you know a very specific
scientist but what are the things that
you know we're maybe not thinking about
enough in terms of the conferences we go
to the venues that we publish and the
ways that we communicate what are the
things that we do well that we need to
do more of and what are the the things
that maybe you know we aren't really on
our radar in terms of the way that we
fruitfully interact with other
disciplines
i
might give a shot so i think the blog i
think um
i think maybe the community i know
andrew garman there's a blog that couple
of people who actually does blog but
relative to other viewing data some have
fewer bloggers so one thing i think
maybe
people can do is really get the whole
team of bloggers because it's hard to
keep pushing things but if you have a
team of bloggers then
the berkeley ai lab we have to take
advantage they have a blog we just you
have time we send a few things and also
diffuse into the ai machine learning
group
at large
and but i think statistic would be nice
to have more vlogs with more bloggers
than just personal blog which have been
really helpful already
i think i don't know about twitter i i
feel like it's too short right sometimes
it's just two by some bite
so i think maybe young people can
organize a blog together
hello yeah
one thing i think you know statisticians
bring to the table is
when when i work with people in the
medical school for example often
someone will come to me and they say oh
they've been trying
one of the new techniques like deep
learning or neural networks on their
data and they got a little bit stuck
you know i think one of the things we
have to offer is we have a whole broad
range of tools we should know about the
new tools
but
a lot of the time some of the simple
tools that we've used all along
just to do just a fine job and if they
do they do it they're much easier to
understand and to work with
you know so bringing the whole range of
statistical tools to the table and
showing you don't always need to use
these new sexy complicated tools you
know but they do have there are places
where they're useful i think that
you know that brings good value to the
table especially these days where people
are asking for explainable ai right
um they want to eventually interpret
what they're doing
you know so i think that's that's
something we can contribute a lot
the question trevor yes uh or was it
supposed to be a question
[Laughter]
do you agree
i still don't
what are the tools a student should be
asked to learn to get a degree in data
science
how much statistics how much calculus
how much computation
does anyone have clear idea what kind of
tools they should have to get a degree
in data science
yeah that's the first question
anybody anybody wants to try and answer
them
what should a degree in data science be
i okay i think i i mean to answer that
question i think there's some there is
some this is almost a
political issue but there is some
argument
for uh
picking i mean given that we have this
glue fact function which we all agree
with
it's trying to actually
just as a label
identify
statistics with data science not have
competing data science and statistics
degrees
and and uh i have to admit this is sort
of a trivial reason
one trivial reason statistics
unfortunately i mean one of the reasons
that that
attention is only now being drawn that
through because of machine learning and
so on is that we have a little bit had
the reputation of economics right we're
the dismal science where the people who
always tell you
you know be careful about this and that
and although this can be useful people
don't like on the whole to be told that
their latest discovery
is worthless
so so so i think
possibly
a re-labeling
in which
you know all these roles we've been
talking about are assumed
this
is worth doing if you can try it also
has the advantage of
i think perhaps giving easier access to
influencing policy
i mean it's
another big comment but
we'll have the next question
here
hi i am jitendra malik i'm a computer
scientist who works on
things like computer vision and machine
learning so i'm going to ask about
a question about that but first i want
to make a comment about peter
i got to know peter in the 1990s when we
first we had a joint project on
transportation so peter men called
himself a theoretician but this was a
project which was on questions like
how long will it take to go from
berkeley to san francisco
on the bay bridge at
8 15 am so i just want people to know
that they are very practical things that
we worked about worked on together with
john rice i don't know if he's here and
praveen varya and others
so but at that time the questions were
about
machine learning
i mean data science was not a term then
in the 1990s but i learned a lot from
peter and from his students and liza
who's committee i served on
so of course last 10 years have been
very big in this field and under the
label of machine learning and of course
the business of
google and facebook and uh
amazon rests on on on this
as a person on the machine learning side
of it i have a little joke which is that
we just know how to give terms we take
the terms that statisticians have and
give it a much more sexy label
and as a result there is a so-called ml
bump right machine learning is worth ten
thousand dollars in the job market for
sure just if you can claim that
but anyway that's a joke aside but
there's a substantial question the
substantial question is
to me goes back to uh
i think leo bryan's
article on the two cultures
and i think at berkeley we have not had
a conflict between statistics and
computer science we have had people with
joint appointments
i think we have worked very nicely
together
but uh the substantial questions in
leo's article from 2001 or three
something like that
was that
practical people care don't care so much
about the probabilistic model they care
a lot about prediction and they have
these prediction questions what's going
to be the price of a house
is this is this bird
robin
and so on and so forth and people like
me we ran with those
so i teach an undergraduate machine
learning class
the difference between my class and the
class that my statistics colleagues will
teach is
i talk all about these cool applications
machine translation recognition
robotics and we we get those students
they come they come to us we seduce them
okay
we you know so and and i think that but
we are in this together so we should
really work together i think the fields
are really it's all the intellectual
space is totally a continuum
so anyway this is a comment but to make
it into a question what do you think of
brian 20 years later
and what does it tell us about what we
should be doing today because data
science is the label i think the
substantial questions are the same as 20
years ago
a great question yeah two cultures 20
years later
yeah so that was
that paper came out right
at my
most
you know persuadable and influenceable
moment
as a as a phd student in statistics at
berkeley
you know working with mike jordan i had
come
to grad school specifically to think
about
kind of the connections between
statistical inference and and
computational approximations i was
excited about all those topics and and
leo kind of wrote this paper saying yeah
that's that's it that's everything for
just predict and don't worry about
parameters their parameters only exist
in your mind and you know and i think
that um
you know he he
the messages of the two cultures paper
were borne out in the sense that you can
get a lot more mileage out of
non-parametric tools for building
prediction rules than you can from low
dimensional parametric tools for
building prediction rules that that is
kind of
you know this is in full
acknowledgement of trevor's point which
is not always but at least sometimes you
can sometimes the complexity actually
helps
um
on the other hand i think what i came
much better to appreciate through taking
215 um
and through interacting with
you know people like david friedman was
that there is there is another slice of
statistics about causation
and if you're solving a prediction
problem that's great you're solving a
prediction problem but prediction
problems are really qualitatively
different than causal inference problems
um and
you know the two cultures paper i think
doesn't have a lot to say
about causation and it there was a
i don't know i wouldn't call it a sin of
a mission but leo was out to make i
think in my view a very particular point
about the efficacy of different
approaches to solving prediction
problems
but in the course of doing that he gave
an account which could be misunderstood
as an account of all of statistical
culture
right and there is there is more going
on in statistics
than explanation and prediction there's
also causation
um and i think it is just a different
category
so um
i would say uh you know leo was was was
right about many things in that paper um
my my view is that it was the points
that he wanted to make were largely
borne out but he was silent on points
that i think the the discussants even of
that paper were already raising about
what what he didn't even address
i i i the only thing that i would
disagree on is that you lumped
prediction in with explanation
and i don't think it's the same thing in
in in a way it's
i mean prediction is is certainly
something
we all value and which is a a criterion
of goodness
but in order to to develop things
right to to
to go to the next level i mean that's
this remember on that in in ben's thing
you know this arrow going backwards
you have to be able to
able to interpret
understand
how it is that you've been successful in
prediction
in order
to improve that prediction in others
that's that's that's different
okay um
okay david cox actually
wrote uh to this statistical science
article in the discussion
uh the prediction should be validated in
new contexts
and that is a robustness question it's
very much tied to the causal question
and of course if we look at prediction
in the broader context i mean like in
economics
the prediction of a new policy of course
that is the causal question i mean the
experts know that but i think sometimes
when people talk about prediction it's
it's a much broader context and i think
even people in causality would be happy
if they can predict an intervention
whether this is now really causal or not
that's not so important but that would
already be a big step forward so i think
i sometimes argue a bit well yeah
prediction but prediction
the usual thing what we have in mind
okay it's our f hat x right but of
course in the next broader level it
becomes much more an explainable
issue and a causal issue so just want to
make that comment
also i think there's also
things i read about a definition
causality i like quite kind of like what
peter was saying
is that the causal causality is really
evident so that you can act on it
and that kind of move away from the
mechanistic but it's become evidence
driven and also can be
evaluated even without a mechanism
but i think
we kind of go back to a full circle
right we went to machine learning or
machine learning people took things and
made new names
and now the machine learning people are
doing experimental ai and i think it's a
great time for us to teach people by
saying that you know yeah we can do it
with you and we have been here
for a much longer time
but the key is the newer problems that
even we say that logistics regression is
interval but it's not if you have a
million parameter intelligence
regression so so so if you work with the
er doctor right decision rules are
interval but for er doctor they probably
only want time splits but if you do
preventative medicine then you can have
maybe more decisions so a lot of the
context also matters and we cannot just
say that while decisions are interval
therefore we're done so it's really the
specifics will drive the next generation
of interpretability and then bring
our skills to solving the problem and
really bring a lot of things back to
statistics and
then i think the field would really
be very prosperous
um well i think this is actually a great
question on which to end
um thank you all for participation let's
thank all of our panelists
so um